hey guys Oren here we're at the Glendale
fighting club with UFC champion Ronda
Rousey it's awesome in a minute I'm
gonna be in the ring with Ronda Rousey
getting my ass kicked for comedy myself
Oh Toki
I wouldn't think oh there's a woman who
fights and gets punched all the time I
think oh here's a woman who lives in the
Alps and Miggs butter oh thank you
haven't seen my gears though oh yeah
you've got a little bit of that fighter
ear calm out here call here you're a
vegan so you know that's LAN I would eat
here you're in the chili monks I like to
wear these blue argyle fleece socks that
I call my jam jams it sounds really
comfortable hi there great naked I would
probably want some iced tea I've lost
this round you should do yoga this is
called crupp yeah yeah that was not a
comedy fall in seven safety word I'll
just start peeing my pants and cry
you'll know when it happens when turning
red you were already man you smell pre
nothing is impossible except cold fusion